[Music]
what is the story with skinny razor
skinny was a stone killer one day during
the snowstorm he grabbed my uncle said
come on let's go they walked in
snowstorm because nobody was out driving
or anything they went in the store and
they killed this guy who was the
informer and they cut his balls off and
they stuck it in his mouth and that's
how my uncle got Bob we're killing
people it was my uncle Nick Scarfo to
get made you always got to kill somebody
and with him he wanted me to kill two
people so I said Vince the refrigerator
get some ice and all we'll have some
drinks so as soon as you turn around
they shot him back at head what's the
reaction when you're looking at it
nothing no zero no I thought I was doing
a good thing first and you got killed he
was the biggest drug dealer and fall off
here sold tested was blown up but a bomb
went off in the blast blew him all the
way to the back door this is what we do
this is what we are were killers so you
knew when Sally's hit was coming before
it happened it was sickening
so this kind of sounds crazy too to live
like crazy yeah we had to be crazy to be
in the mob you just can't become the
boss you got to get approved by the
Commission so they're protecting each
other in a way yeah if you want to kill
a boss this is what's gonna happen
why wouldn't they pick you guys up we're
in the mob to make money besides killing
everybody what exactly did we do wrong
did you ever think you would make you
like it takes sweet victory I know this
slice meant for me yeah why would you
bet on Goliath when we got red tape
value Kaman given values contagious this
world of entrepreneurs we can't no value
the haters honey run homie look what I
become I'm the one
[Music]
so the last time I guessed that an
interview was with John Miller from CBS
in 2013 and John well if you don't know
who he is he interviewed Osama bin Laden
he flew out to go have a private
interview with Osama bin Laden and my
guest today Philip Leonetti has only
done two interviews one was that and one
was he did a few years prior to it and
this is his third one and when we do the
interview today the reason for this is
because you obviously know we've
interviewed a lot of people from
different crime families but many of you
were requesting someone to sit down with
us from Philadelphia and Atlantic City
and the main name when you think about
that today it's Philip Leonetti so we
reached out we spoke to use attorney we
were able to make this work and it was
kind enough to fly out and sit down with
us here today so Phil thanks for coming
out thank you for having me so before we
before we get into the interview I have
the one obvious question before I got a
list of questions that I want to get
into with you is it's been a long time
since you left a life right and and
Nicky Scarfo your boss your uncle passed
away in 2017 why are you still
uncomfortable revealing yourself when
you're doing an interview well you never
know there's a lot of crazy people out
there that want to be gangsters that
figure if they do run into me or
recognize me somewhere I'll take a shot
at me and make themselves a big man they
could you know go to Philadelphia and
say yeah I killed Phil Leonetti so I'm
always careful got it so even after
these minute these many years I always
watch myself yes even after all these
years when you're when you're going out
and and you're sitting in restaurants or
places or walking are you always you
know aware of your surroundings and
what's going on i watch myself yes I am
even till today even till today not only
be close to the map-request
of today with everybody with the guns
and shootings you never know you run
into crazy people today now were you
always would you consider yourself a
little bit paranoid or no you would you
would say more cars murderin cautious
okay paranoid my uncle was a very
paranoid sure about everything but no I
was careful I was his bodyguard 24 hours
a day and it came from that that's it's
something that's embedded in me comes
natural okay yeah that's what I kind of
was going towards would you like that
before you decided to join the
life and was it always a way you were
you were a little bit more cautious and
more careful okay so now let's go back
let's go back to how this whole thing
got started so you're going through what
you're going through your father leaves
the picture he's no longer there you
move to duck town and you're there with
your mother how does the life get
started for you when did you go from
just being Phil Leonetti to you know
getting hooked up with your uncle
well my uncle when my uncle moved to
Atlantic City we he started to take me
under his wing you know we would bring
me hunting with him bring me different
places and and he would talk to me about
this thing
lacrosse an awesome room and which I
really didn't understand at that time
but he would tell me about we're
different than everybody else
we don't live the same life as the
government you know they have different
rules than we do and he was me you know
that respect and honor and that's the
way you know he groomed me you know grew
up mm-hmm I grew up like that yeah how
old were you at that time when you see
787 I'm sorry yeah again I have an
eight-year-old son you mean to tell me
at seven years old he's having these
conversations oh yeah you even took me
around that time seven eight nine maybe
ten years old he took me for a ride in
this truck he told me just killed this
bad man who disrespected our family and
he was talking to
not our family La Casa Nostra family
mm-hmm that's what he meant and he said
look I'm gonna take you with me so it
doesn't look suspicious like I'm I'm
doing something wrong so you'd be like a
little bit of a decoy and we drove the
Philadelphia in this pickup truck where
they carried the body and buried buried
this man that he killed and he told me
the whole reason why he killed them that
he slapped one of our one of the family
members and disrespected our men also he
told me how he killed them and where
they killed him he told me the whole
story and made me feel like wow he's
telling me all this he made me feel like
a big man almost like he's trusting you
they're close to me yeah now at that
time who is the man you're looking up to
was there somebody in your life that you
could look up to and say you know this
man is gonna protect me I can one day be
like cameras or anyone like yeah it was
like at that time it was my uncle Nick
Scarfo it was him
yeah and outside of him nobody nobody
okay so you didn't have somebody else to
look up don't know there was no other
man there was my grandfather he was
older and sick and then it was just my
mother and my grandmother it was your
mother cautious of you getting close to
Nicky or now yeah she was she even at
that at that time you know she didn't
realize anything at that time but as I
got older and she seen the way I was
going the direction I was going she kept
telling me to stay away from him was
that already too late at that time yeah
yeah I didn't listen to her what age was
it when she started telling you Phil you
know you may wonder but when I was right
Aven well junior or senior in high
school Connor okay so you were already
long enough around him to be influenced
by his mindset oh yeah he tells you the
story about who he killed and why he
killed them that experience takes place
as a kid outside of the fact that why
this guy's sharing it with me did you
have any other reaction to say I can't
believe we just killed somebody and it's
not a big deal why is he talking to me
like it's not a big deal was there any
reaction like now now at that age no I
didn't feel like scared or anything I
felt like that he did a good thing the
way he explained it to me was a good
thing for the family got it it was
respect and honor and this is what we're
supposed to do this is our life and
where you were living at and Ducktown
was that was there a lot of a mob was it
was that pretty public that everybody
know what they liked admired what was
the conditions like and duck and where
we lived well eventually everybody knew
who we worked yet he knew who my uncle
was and then as I got older and I had a
reputation myself hmm everybody knows
newspapers would be writing about us all
the time because we killed a lot of
people but when you were 8 9 10 years
old coming up was there a big mob
presence they were not real no it wasn't
no there was no ma presence just my own
pretty safe place pretty chill place yes
okay it's almost like how Compton was
years ago where there wasn't a lot of
crime and in all of San Compton became
what it became and and folks okay that's
good to know
okay so from there you're going through
high school you're not yet dropped out
of high school you're doing school
regularly he's not asking you to leave
school yet right nothing's happening
you're still going full-time yeah and in
what direction are you going are you
going with the intention of saying one
day I'm gonna run with my uncle or
are you going into school saying I'm
gonna grow up to be XYZ you know I was
thinking maybe I was want to go with my
uncle but you know then back in my mind
I wanted to play basketball I wanted to
go or maybe this college but what
happened he wind up getting a subpoena
from the state commission of
Investigation and they he was in yard
ville for a couple years so at that time
after high school I started driving my
mother my grandmother his wife and son
to go see him and yard gnome in yard
ville in Yorkville and what was that
like every time you're going there's you
asking you for favors or is he still
just kind of but you know trying to
influence you in shape well he's telling
well no I'm this is like my job now it's
my duty I'm part of the family so I'm
taking them twice a week and eventually
start giving me messages to bring back
to Phil testa and about things going on
and all and at that time Phil test does
the boss Phil testa was the underboss
Angelo Bruno was in prison right Bruno
has not been killed yet so right justice
still yeah underboss yes got it so they
are they already are you already an
associate or you still kind of come up
now or definitely necessary messages
about killing people at that time he was
trying to get the okay to kill Alvin
Fellman and with ang in there he kept
pressing ang since they did were right
next to each other in each in the cells
about killing them so they were waiting
for Pappy Eppolito which is Angel's
cousin to collect like fifty thousand
from album before they killed him so
while you're going back and forth you're
still in school I just graduated you've
already graduated high school okay so in
high school if I'm in high school with
you who was Phil Leonetti in high school
I was a basketball player I was a pretty
good basketball player and all my
friends most of them became cops my good
friend Ronny became a cop which I still
see today and I was a basketball for
everybody knew me as a basketball player
and that was it nobody knew the
reputation of my uncle or my family or
anything like nobody knew no I'm not not
in the school so you didn't have your
blow-ups you didn't knock anybody I know
I was another guy anyway yeah no I
yeah I know I saw one of the one your
classmate said he was a nicest guy he
said he wasn't weak he was strong but he
wasn't somebody that would get into
fights smart guy you know some of your
classmates were talking about you yeah
oh yeah yeah
interesting so so then you end up high
school you finish high school you get
out you're going back and forth you're
Dean doing these delivering these
messages at what point do you get to the
point where you say I think this is the
life I'm going to live 100% I'm not at
that time
yeah at that time when I start driving
it back and forth I knew I wasn't going
anywhere
I was stay in there with him and is this
something you're excited about is this
something like at that point or like I
can't wait to live this life what are
you thinking at that time I always
looked at it it was like my duty more
than being excited it was just I was
just doing it that's this is my family
and this is what I'm supposed to do and
at this point of the game your uncle is
not yet climbed up to the top right he
has not yet become the massive presence
and the power that he has in the streets
with the different families how
different was did you see a level of
almost like an evolution of your uncle
of how he was then at 18 years old
versus at 26 with Falcone too you know
year after year after year did you see
him changing or was he the same at 18 as
he was at the end well his ego grew as
he got more popular and as we killed
more people he got you know reputation
for killing people which he loved he
loved that reputation he mostly was you
know he went by the laws of La Cosa
Nostra mostly mostly at that time yeah
okay so by the time you're 18 how many
stories do you know about how many
people he's personally killed by the
time you're 18 that he personally killed
it must have been about five or six when
I was around 18 that you knew about that
I knew about and it could be more that's
just the five you know it yeah did I
know about got it and for him it wasn't
a big deal it was something that he just
did it was a part of his job that he
chose how many of those five or six that
he killed were assignments that were
given to him how many of it was just
purely reaction somebody said something
offended him and he pulled the trigger
there was one that he did on his own
that he almost got in a lot of trouble
for with Angelo Bruno
him and that other fellow named mark
that was also me guy they killed this
guy and even he told me the whole story
about how he was bothering my mother how
they got friendly with the guy they took
him for a ride and he said he had this
45 and he said they stopped the car to
get out like they were going to take a
leak and when the guy got out of the car
he said he shot him like four times he
held him up in the air like he was
bragging about that the way the gun the
45 actually held him up didn't make the
guy fall it was hitting them and the guy
was against the car and he kept hitting
them and every time the guy went to fall
he hit him again and bounced him back up
and he's saying this he's telling you
from a place of joy like this was an
interesting experience and is he
encouraging you to you know like this is
gonna be great when you one day do it is
he taking that approach I know he's just
sharing stories with he'll know we
always told me you know to get into this
to get this which means La Cosa Nostra
to get made you always got to kill
somebody and with him he wanted me to
kill two people you know he says you
know just because I'm here I'm your
uncle it doesn't mean anything in this
life you've got to obey the rules you
got to listen I can't help you if you
get in trouble so at this point you're
18 you're driving them to the you know
prison a couple times you're coming back
and forth you're doing some favors to
$50,000 this is happening what's next
what does it go to the point where I
know at 26 years old was the first time
you killed somebody yourself but what
are you doing at this time you know
what's going on with his own events you
know what he's moving up in the ranking
well he was in jail for two years and
when he got out he had a little bit of
reputation stuff you went around
visiting everybody like to testify Frank
Monti we just started moving around
Philadelphia is he at this point an
earner or not yet not yet we get hooks
he well he did get hook up with a fella
named sy whole frige kind a guy that he
helped a couple years back with a loan
and all and he made them partners in a
bar in Atlantic City so he would go
there every night we would all hang
there every night and this is how he was
making his money he started making money
like that now money money is he making
real money at this time we're not making
a little bit of you know he's making
money to survive what's the money what
so what's some money at that time yeah a
thousand a week
oh okay so he's not yet making you know
that's not happening yet not yet so what
what
is what what even caused the boss to ask
Nikki to go from Philly from
Philadelphia to go to a Atlantic City
what what even caused that what happened
was it was an Angelo Bruno Villa send
them to Atlantic City my uncle when he
was younger was a bookmaker for his
uncle's which are his mother's brothers
and they only gave him a salary they
kept them down they didn't give him a
lot of money and he hated him for it he
worked like 12 years for them and he
said he was better off doing a life bit
in prison than working for them so
eventually got disgusted with them and
just moved to Atlantic City and my
grandmother had a big apartment building
and he lived in one in appointments
there because you hear two different
stories one is he chose to go up there
one is they asked him to leave because
he was causing too much havoc and
somebody wanted to take him out and they
didn't want him to be around you know he
was too much trouble he's making too
much noise he's gonna expose us so your
version of the stories he chose to go to
Atlantic City yeah he chose to go to
Atlantic City nobody was going to take
him out especially anybody in
Philadelphia anybody in Philadelphia
which would you say even his bosses
feared him yes definitely Angelo Bruno
he was careful like yeah he definitely
feared us because especially as he
started getting people random like it
was me and Chucky and Laurence and then
Vince Falcone and just saw the felony
alfredo forever he started to get a
little crew together as we and you know
when we were killing people we killed
the Marco at the incident motel and and
that was for chickie Narducci Angelo
Bruno water we got the okay to kill hell
fine you know I mean the judge hell so
this is pre Atlantic City this is in
Atlantic City this is in Atlantic City
no I I guess what I'm asking for what
what was happening in Philadelphia where
you know Bruno and and some of these
folks were getting concerned about
skarphol trying to make too much of a
vertical leap what you said they're
scared of them why were they scared
about was he well it was reputation
they knew his reputation Angelo Bruno no
he was a gangster and he was just
careful of them and Angela wasn't a
gangster himself now he was more like a
businessman he was more of a businessman
methodical I hear he was a genius by the
way when it comes out to be
and money those doses yeah but what he
would do like when my uncle was sent you
know went to him said look I'm going to
do something with this I hope fridge
mm-hmm right outside of Philadelphia
he's going to open up in the mall there
he's gonna open up this big bar and
restaurant and insulin I don't don't
forget about it that's that's not a good
thing to do and all he he told him not
to do it the meantime he sends his
son-in-law
the back door my uncle to try to get Bob
what's I to do the job with them you
know to get involved with him so sight
told my uncle and my uncle just wind up
going apartness with him anyway and then
and she couldn't do anything about it
too late because I mean he could kill
him for not listening to him what they
were like a little worried about us why
didn't one do I didn't want to if
they're thinking that you could
potentially really create some ruckus
there why wouldn't they take you guys
out what's their what's the consequences
before there will be a war with us I
mean they would have a big problem
trying if they just make you out if they
took my uncle laughs yeah yeah they
would have a big problem big problem
with us yeah and plus there has to be a
good reason why would you I mean what
exactly did we do wrong so there wasn't
a reason yet no okay so so let me by the
way you seemed very proud of the about
the fact that you you got you guys were
strong and you were feared by them it
even though it's been many years yeah
so the consiglieri of angelo bruno is
named as joe i believe right Joe Rogan's
how do you say his last very good yes
Joe yeah Joe took a liking to your uncle
right Nicky and because they were both
from Naples or so in Calabria yeah and
at one point there's a story about Joe
wanted him to marry his daughter and
Nikki told him to his face I'd never
marry your ugly daughter is that a myth
or is that the truth no it wasn't my
uncle it was chucking really know Chucky
morally no didn't want to marry yeah he
one daughter
yeah I wanted him to marry his daughter
and after he like didn't want to marry
his daughter he wanted to kill Chucky
now how was Chucky connected to Nikki
Chucky
started hanging with my uncle when he
was 16 years old is he family or his joy
yes okay friend his father knew my uncle
Chucky's father so at this point of the
game Nikki hasn't publicly in
all to the bus yet there's not been an
insult now it's pretty you know to by
the rules he's following the rules he's
protecting a family I'm still certain
point
yeah he's following the rules up to a
certain point like with this bar and all
I mean he didn't listen to him because
the Ange went behind his back tried to
grab it for himself because he was
money-hungry
Nicky was no Angelo Bruno Angelo Bruno
he's the one that was making 12 million
dollars a month at the time he was
making a lot he was the biggest drug
dealer in Philadelphia Angelo Bruno
believe it or not and one of the rules
is to not do any other drugs yeah did
that annoy Nicky the fact that he was
touching drugs well we you know we
couldn't say anything about it
interesting so you go to Atlantic City
at what point in Atlantic City
do you guys start making real money one
of gambling cane garden casino gambling
cane we got hooked up with jeans we had
them all all the unions you're dealing
with you and Ian and this is kind of
give you an upper hand you know just
giving you an edge on doing more
business at this point of the game in
Atlantic City are you guys making good
money we're making a lot of money what's
a lot of money well I know he was making
at least 20,000 a month with the Union
so 20 okay one account that's 20,000 a
month we started a shakedown business
which soul king who was an associate of
ours came up with called at the elbow we
would go around to people in legitimate
businesses and say look who gave you the
okay to start this business you owe us
money
we're being an illegal business because
we're here to protect you if you have a
problem with anybody else because
anybody could shake you down so your own
art paper all yours start paying us and
that's what we did he went around all
Northeast Philadelphia all south we had
guys going all over the place we've had
a ton of money coming in and and what is
that accounting to what kind of number
is that help what kind of numbers of
money you're getting all these illegal
guys that are paying you what I don't
know a few hundred thousand a month that
kind of work yeah so there's no was big
money at this point you guys are making
real money yeah okay because not only
they were shaking down even though we
were not drug dealers but we were
shaking down drug dealers we were
allowed to shake down drug dealers and
we were making scores with two to three
hundred thousand dollars at a time with
them so now you're up there you guys are
starting to make some money you're
making a
a hundred thousand dollars a month have
you yet been ordered to kill somebody or
not not yet yeah we killed pepê lima I
think in 1976 I believe you did or or no
was Alfredo but I was involved with it
okay I was being followed by the
Atlantic County Prosecutor's Office at
that time so five o'clock in the morning
I'm in the my way lands with all the
prosecutors which they're watching me
and that's the morning he gets killed
and they still arrested me for the
murder you were able to get off and
nothing happens yeah I got off yeah how
many times at this point have you been
arrested before you're 26 well I think
was that time and then in 1980 for the
murder of in Chappelle that's it yeah
yeah I have a record you so you stay
clean you were low-key yeah okay so at
26 years old walk us through what
happens when your order to go out there
and kill Falcone well we planed that me
and my uncle and Lawrence that we were
going to take Vince to this house that
one of our associates owned and Marquis
was right on the beach and it was
wintertime nobody's around so he decided
to my uncle decided let's bring this
fellow Joe Salerno was hanging around us
at this time he's a legitimate guy he
was a plumber he says we'll take him
with us to make Vince feel more
comfortable because Vince felt like he
was going to get killed
of course him and now Fredo went to
Chuck E and Philadelphia to complain
about my uncle so anyway we set up a
thing that we were going to watch
something over this film mcfillin's
house my gauge so I say come on Vince
will take a ride over there so meet him
Lawrence and Joe Salerno went over here
we wrote down there and my uncle was
already there in the house and we went
in and he looked at as soon as we got to
the top of the steps he looked like he
was going to run down the steps so I
started to say come on let's let's have
a drink you know he has an idea what's
about yeah he looked yeah suspicious but
I think him seeing joseline are there
kept them a little calm so I said Vince
the refrigerator could get some ice and
we'll have some drinks so as soon as you
turned around they shot him back at head
how you feeling at this time when you
did this I'd have any feelings towards
them I figure I'm doing the right thing
for the family he's talking about my
uncle he's cursing I'm insane he's crazy
he's not
right thing so this is what we do this
is what we are were killers I mean
especially with my uncle so you shoot
him once and then what else shot him
once she fell down uncle said shoot him
again he tested he wanted to see if you
heard a heartbeat so I shot him again in
the chest and that was it then I left he
told me that we even get rid of the gun
and when they tied him up and then put
him in the trunk of his car and parked
this car and market somewhere so they
put him in the trunk of his own car yes
and it parked it in the market
yeah now at that time when you're doing
this are you worried about fingerprints
are you wearing gloves is there any oh
yeah we had gloves we cleaned up the
blood which you really can't clean up
blood but I mean if they hit the
backlight but you'll see where blood was
but there was no evidence that we were
there until Joe Salerno saw and
testified against this so you're leaving
you're done you did your first hit are
you feeling proud is there any emotions
that you have that was actually my
second one that's your second one how
are you feeling at this time just good
yeah yeah normal there was as a matter
of fact when I got to the office after I
got rid of the gun I called the radio
station and there was a fella this Joe
disco was Joseph Edie's son now Joe
Scaffidi was a made guy
in our family his sons a radio disc
jockey so I call them much they played a
song do or die as a joke and that was it
and I waited for them to come back my
uncle when they finally got back my
uncle was falling down drunk we had to
hold him up he was so drunk he couldn't
stand up and it's first time he grabbed
me and hugged me kissed me and told me
he loved me is that the first time ever
first time ever and only only yeah I was
it what was your reaction my I couldn't
believe it like well I was shocked so it
was nice I thought good and he never did
that no never ever so how did he win
your loyalty what was his style because
there's different styles of winning
loyalty what was his style it was just I
just felt like you know we were blood
and it was just something that I was
born into and I had to do the right
thing I figured he's my uncle and you
know he's teaching me the right thing to
do so you said this was not the first
one this was your second hit the first
one you're saying is this a first one
you pulled the trigger or now there was
another one you pull now the first one I
pulled the trigger was me and Vincent
Falcone killed the fella that was
robbing chicken our duties crap
his name was DeMarco that's the first
one that's the first one right yeah
ensign motel yeah and you kill them or
did follow I killed him you killed him I
killed them because I ran out first and
he got stuck in in the room and when I
first shot him in the back of the head
like he flew I thought he was running
away but it was the force of the bullet
and who that made him run that made him
fly like that so and then we just didn't
he came over we just empty the guns into
him what's the reaction when you're
looking at it nothing no zero no I
thought I was doing a good thing so when
you get in the car and you're driving to
it Falcone what are you guys talking
it's just you know we actually my uncle
picked us up with flowers yeah we had
wheel a lady doubt nothing we don't talk
in the car at all nothing just that we
got back to the house Finch went to his
house and you know we came up I was in
the shower and my uncle came in the
shower make sure you scrub your
fingernails get all the Gunpowder out
and clean yourself in all this we got
rid of the clothes and all were you
always worried about being the wiretap
it would being listened to so where did
you feel comfortable talking to each
other well you're not being wiretapped
away from cars places walking on the
street somewhere like maybe in the
corner where's we we would look around
there's no cameras there was a scene
where they even heard you speaking to
each other and you were out in the
street so there was no specific basement
place you'd go to there was now like a
place you know we won't go to one spot
all the time you wouldn't go to one at a
time guy ever and we wouldn't stain your
cars to speak either because we always
felt the car would pick up us if we were
standing close to the car and back then
it's so because the things have changed
so dramatically versus today versus then
because today today forget about it you
know you really got to be careful yeah I
mean the whole story with we were
talking about last night where one of
the former mobsters you're sitting on is
how come you don't have a new iPhone so
well the iPhone is a perfect way to be a
detective that's exactly where I member
says the old flip phones you know you
you can't really track me any any things
you had where you were like you can't
carry this you can't carry that you
can't carry this because it's a tracking
system was any protocols that that time
okay yes I would have cellphones
especially at the bus terminal there was
nine million cell phones and that's when
I had to call somebody cell phones are
you mean
like pay phone pay phones yes I'm
changed right yes so use the payphones
yeah that that and you felt like what's
a payphone oh yeah because I would use
different ones got it can see on the
move
yeah so when you when you made the
second move and you killed Falcone you
leave you you're not thinking anything's
gonna happen and if somebody goes in
turns in and says you did the job yeah
what happens then well we get arrested
if they're about a week my grandmother
put her buildings up for her for our
bail mm-hmm and we got out we had a
trial going how did you get out of that
one they had evidence but you got two
fantastic lawyers there
did they buy out any cops on this one or
no actually we did yeah
when we presented our case we put this
guy who was a market police officer they
used to follow us all the time and he
said he knew our car and he was driving
by that house at that time and didn't
see our car and we paid him my uncle
gave him like three thousand dollars to
say that understand and that almost
actually our defense almost lost us the
case we should have just finished the
case after the prosecution because even
the jury told us he said you guys you
guys almost blew the case I mean by you
know having because we had different
people that were there like one older
fellow that was a bartender at the green
house where this house is says he didn't
see my uncle's car but we took a break
for lunch and when he came back he was
drunk you know and he's on the stand
talking he's not knowing what he's
talking about so we could really blew
the case by putting a defense on we were
good right after the prosecution rested
her so with or without him you were
gonna be fine you didn't need him
waiting
okay got it so you leave now when you
leave and you're you just kill somebody
and you got off the stand are you
feeling untouchable at this point are
you feeling like you know what I yes we
felt great we've really felt great we're
on a roll
this is 19 October of 1980 we won that
case and then the following year Phil
testa got blown up how did that well
first and you got killed naturally and
then Phil testa was blown up cuz there's
some real bomb no bomb this is the nail
bomb making it look like which the
roofers that killed him it goes back to
Angelo
Bruno who got Tony captain arrow to be
his console here
mm-hmm and Tony actually didn't like get
along with Ange he wanted to make mo he
wanted to be the boss too so he went to
New York to complain about ang because
he was friendly with the guys in New
York and this Frank Thierry and this
fella told him said look dude do what
you got to do when ang strained it out
you know so he took it where the guy was
telling him to kill Angelo Buono so he
set it up where John Stanford would drop
the window where they were parked out in
front of Angelo Bruno's house and as
they were sitting there talking Stamford
lowered his window and Tony hit him with
a shotgun behind his head and killed him
and after that every maybe everything
went really crazy we didn't know who did
it and everything really went bad now
I've heard a lot of different versions
of why Angelo got killed what what story
do you know why he got killed he wanted
to take over he wanted to be the boss
gotta that's that's pretty much it
that's it Wow that and by being the boss
you're gonna have a ton of money coming
in he was shaking down Long John
as soon as Ainge was killed he grabbed
Long John who was Angelo Bruno's big
earner cause he was the drug dealer and
told him how much he wants and how my
asked him how much you make how much you
got coming in and this is how much I
want this is how much I want you just
got to give me what I what's he making
at the time before he I tell you they
were selling that p2p from what we found
out and he came in 55-gallon drums and
contractors cement contractors who would
use it by throwing it in the concrete
from what I understand they would make a
half a million dollars on the 55-gallon
drums they would get the drums for
nothing of course they contractors
didn't know what they were using a four
by me p2p with it and they were making a
ton of money after a million dollars per
drum yeah and how many drums were they
moving a ton of them I don't know I'm a
ton was you're not talking like a lot of
them so you said when this happened you
said things got very ugly what does that
mean things out there yeah well we
didn't know who killed ang we wanted to
find out my uncle went to New York
sat down with guys New York was really
upset like you know los has killed the
commission like is saying whoa what's
going on here who could the okay for
this my uncle finally
trying to get everything together find
out what was going on Phil testa didn't
go to New York he was afraid to why's
that
he didn't know anybody in New York and
my uncle was the guy he knew everybody
so as he met with the chin Fat Tony and
everybody trying to find out what
happened they called Frank's and own up
there to find out and and his cousin did
they ever find out who did it they found
out who did it they finally called I
can't think of his name all these things
that were talking about the first time
I'm thinking about him in a long time
and it's actually a good thing it means
that you've gone back to having a normal
life like these are nice things that you
talk about other places ever think about
him you never think about him no not at
all not at all kappa negro so there's a
meeting the cabin Ygritte they call it
the first time they call Caponigro he
don't show up so my uncle's there
waiting they finally okay try and get
ahold of Nick tell him to come so they
sent for him again and they said who
gave you the okay to kill Ange and he
told him about Frankie er said well I
talked to him he gave me the okay and he
said I didn't give you the okay I just
told you to strain it out I didn't tell
you to kill him so right there they
killed him they took him and they they
tortured him they stuck $20 bills off
his ass really gave him a tough way to
die now was this was anybody playing
games behind closed doors that somebody
did manipulate him into kicking him out
yeah okay yeah he flayed him to kill
ants because there was a big bookmaking
business up in North Jersey that Thierry
wanted a piece of and with him out of
the way he had no problem taking it over
if it was played and manipulated that he
did it then why take him out is it to
say that it wasn't our call it was
somebody else that decided to do it
Ainge wasn't popular wasn't popular with
the Commission he'd be close to was here
here's your Paul Castellano type of guy
where he was just a money guy war yeah
he was just a money guy Carlo Gambino
was his man when Carlo Gambino died he
lost all his power ranch I mean a castle
ah no didn't like them none of them guys
really so what's coming everybody know
it's kind of coming yeah so then they
handle the killer the way they do this
oh I didn't tell you to kill him I just
told you you know do what you
to do what happens after that was that a
statement to the marketplace that if you
do anything this the college may be an
example of them yeah you're gonna kill a
boss you're definitely this is what's
going to happen without the okay you
want to kill somebody without get the
okay this is what happens after that
they wanted to make my uncle action to
Boston Philadelphia at that time what he
said no she said Phil test has been done
their boss for a long time he said
Mickey he said no yeah my uncle said no
even as a power-hungry guy like him said
no no he figured he was close with Phil
testa okay and he said look he's been
anxious underboss I know him a long time
he said well they but he'd better make
you the underboss then he said yeah I'm
sure he will
which he did he didn't know he made Pete
Casella his underboss and the reason he
made P casella's underboss cause he's a
cijxij Leon he said gee and he made my
uncle too consigliere it said she is
somebody from Sicily yes okay and and
for full disclosure it's not a curse
Ward it's not a bad word nickname it's a
million for folks from Sicily yes and is
there some rivalry where worse you know
some folks from Italy don't like each
other is there well it's a rivalry where
the civilians think they're the true
Italians and they don't consider anybody
else Italian like we won't be considered
Italian to them
really yeah interesting and that's
pretty obvious everyone it's obvious you
okay and and how what is what matters to
them the most is that money is it right
as a loyalty is low yet their money
people above everything yeah and that's
also known it is it is in the cut so
then what happens next
now this P Casella was a real he used to
be a drug dealer years ago when he said
he was out of the business and all this
he didn't have any money he got hooked
up with chicken or duchi
who had a lot of money and chicky North
Duty talked him into killing
Phil testa mmm-hmm where Pete would
become the boss and chicky Narducci
would become the underboss and he laid a
lot of money on them what happens they
made this plan where the casella's were
good with bombs because he had a brother
Tony could sell also and they had this
kid that said a bomb near Phil touch
this house right next to his door
actually he had a wall concrete wall
here
on his porch so when Phil went to go
open the door to bomb went off in the
blast blew him all the way to the back
door and killed him and Pete thought he
was going to become the boss once he was
killed after that when we went in and
all that he sent for my uncle actually
it was at Phil testa's funeral I wake
I'm sorry wake chicky Narducci was there
and he told my uncle he said Pete
Casella wants to see you at Johnny
Capella's house which is his
brother-in-law so my uncle said could I
bring Chuckie with me and he said I
don't give a [ __ ] who you bring so right
there we knew something was wrong
I grab Johnny Capel I said what's going
on cuz I heard what chicky said he said
oh you made me your uncle shouldn't you
he shouldn't go over there I said why
what's why why shouldn't he go so I told
my uncle I said now we're going so I
grabbed trying to compel I said come on
you're staying with me if something
happened to my uncle me to kill you
right here
so we had him at the 9n bar my uncle
went thank god they came out alive he
said when they first got there there was
this kid that set the bomb I had a radio
listening for police calls in his ear so
they walked in Pete was there as brother
Tony Pete said look we know who killed
Phil testa he's telling my uncle and my
uncle said Yahoo he said it was the
roofers Union we want you to kill John
McCullough because he's the one he said
John McCole didn't kill Phil testa he
said I just send Ralph Napoli to the
chin to find out what's going on over
here I'm gonna send a message that
you're telling me McCullough killed Phil
testa and we'll see what happens Pete's
a talk why we want to cost problems now
you know he said no this is this is what
we're going to do he send ralph napoli
over there to find out what was going on
and all so my Uncle Sam word with Ralph
up to the chin to make an appointment to
go see them mm-hmm to find out what's
going on
so he told Pete Pete was really upset
about that cause he figured you know
it's going to it's going to come out
that he was in Bob would kill him Phil
testa so anyway they left there waiting
for Ralph to come back had the
appointment with the chin and they went
up he went up the next day he told him
about what Pete said and all and told
him that he was lying about it so they
sent for pica so they did and your
reasoning for doing this is for things
to not get
to control where you were you just kind
of trying to protect yourself as well we
were trying yet we were trying to find
out who killed them we know we didn't do
it because if you won't go the wrong
route and you assume that somebody that
who didn't it could turn into mayhem
yeah Oh God we have to find out who
really killed him we knew it wasn't John
McCullough what was in the roofers a
union they put the nails in the and the
bomb to make it look like it was coming
from the roofers Union were they
assuming or were they trying to play a
power game against you guys what were
they trying to kind of a you know
deflect it on somebody it was trying to
deflect them but the money who killed
them yeah okay I know
so who killed them it was Pete Casella
and checking our duty and all the kids
they had around them what's the motive
for them doing that Pete one is
beautiful us because he fun
figures once he becomes the boss I'll
make chicken or through cheating on
their boss he'll make a ton of money
chicken would lay a lot of money on them
but see chicky didn't you understand you
just can't become the boss you got to
get approved by the Commission to be the
boss of thought off you mm-hmm so they
didn't understand that they thought they
could just become the boss on their own
but they got to be approved and they
found out the hard way so what happens
next so what happens next
we wanted to kill Pete and Tony but they
didn't give us the okay the Commission
didn't give us the okay to kill Pete so
they said well you go to Florida you're
retired get out of here you're done
topeka sella his brother Tony we got the
okay to kill him chicky Narducci deal
the fellows the kid they made the bomb
everybody involved we got the okay to
kill everybody you got the green light
for everybody everybody except for Pete
now let me ask you this the Commission
who is in the Commission the bosses are
the five families okay so when you go to
the Commission do the folks the bosses
are the fine families and the Commission
are they pretty loyal to the idea of if
somebody comes and tells you we got to
take somebody and they agree on it they
don't leak the information to nobody no
they don't
now even though their enemies a little
bit yeah I know lucky set up the
Commission but even though some of the
guys may be their own guys you're okay
to give the green light to say yep he
did this wrong you got to go do it
definitely the boss gets killed
especially a sitting boss that's on the
Commission I mean Phil testa was on the
commission he was a sitting boss they
want to find out who did it and they
want
they want to kill everybody involved
what's their motive for wanting to do
that to protect themselves as they said
on the nation' okay so they're
protecting each other in a way yes the
Commission so is that kind of what led
to Nikki being the boss yeah Danny after
that my uncle put his his name in the
ring he was going around meeting all the
captains and all said that you know he
wanted to be the boss you got the okay
from New York the Commission so he
becomes the boss he picks his capo he
picks his underboss what's the process
of him picking his team he made me a
captain you made shall be tested captain
Chuck you'd younger boys Frank Monty to
consigliere why did he choose Chucky as
the underboss they were there's his
buddy it was just you know he was it
with him since he was 16 years old did
all of you kind of assume Chucky was
going to be Bo yeah so it wasn't
something that wasn't known you knew
that was gonna take place yes okay so at
this point now he's a boss okay
and he was a kind of boss that he wanted
everybody know he's a boss he wasn't
somebody that wanted to be a low-key guy
it's not a nationality now he wanted
everybody in the streets to know we're
dangerous oh yeah he cross us yeah
things can happen
he said we're sending guys out a little
replace to shake people down is was that
all the bosses approached as well as
Nikki's or no not all bosses had Nikki's
of origin everybody's different my
uncles approach was more he's a killer
his favorite expression was that gotta
shoot him got to keep killing I can't
stop killing just keep killing him
what's the motive behind that to put the
fear into everybody here yeah so he
controlled a hundred percent with fear
everybody was all the other bosses and
the Commission's same approach to lead
with fear everybody was different give
me an example he was different
look at Paul Castellani he was a
businessman chin Jim was a tough guy Fat
Tony they were tough guys but they just
didn't want to go out and start killing
people I mean it it shakes everybody up
in the family you know like them the
movie with Paul Muni you know Scarface
he was that type of he was a gangster he
was a over-the-top gangster he went a
little too far let's talk about the life
of a mobster at this time you're a cop
oh he's the boss what's the life looking
like what still you know I know you guys
had a outdoor a boat called the usual
suspects you would go party on that
what's it looking like would you know
going to nightclubs women cars travel
partying with celebrities is that
experience already taking place or not
yet my experience
as a captain I had a crew under me that
I took care of and I was also his
bodyguard I was with him constantly I
mean when I left him he was home in the
house or he was somewhere else
my life was 24 hours around him are you
having any fun at this time are you fun
it was are you going to the club and
there's five girls hey Phil no no Club I
will go out what soul came once a while
have a few drinks and I would I'm type
of guy we just sit down Stoll was a good
talker he would just keep talking and
all and I would listen no we had a few
drinks and relax a little bit so this
wasn't a womanizer temple bug nobody in
the group was as a womanizer Lawrence
was like America's host he would go out
with a lot of different types of girls
he was he was good
he's a character he was a character man
was Nikki or no Nikki was my uncle now
he had a girlfriend natural he was
married but he had a girlfriend and
that's it yeah nothing wild nothing out
of control because that's pretty normal
in debt to have a girlfriend on the side
yeah but nothing where it's you're
running through with girls left and
right no no no that wasn't her style so
so then what was your style was it more
how are you enjoying yourself while
you're doing this well we went how we I
mean wanted nice dinners you want the
shows in the casino before we got thrown
out
well you're partying with celebrities
were you partying with the people that
were known not really now celebrities
not big celebrities you know celebrities
in Atlantic City you perform there we
would know if you were down but but
that's about it I mean II knew Emmitt
Sinatra and Sammy Davis jr. Dean Warren
he was friendly with them but nothing
big nothing crazy now so so you know
it's something some of these movies the
way they portray what the life was like
and how much fun and how much of a blast
they had you know being in the mob you
didn't experience that part at all no I
didn't I was a 24-hour bodyguard for my
uncle that was my life when we would go
to dinner I would go with him you know
we would be a bunch of guys or if he was
out with his girlfriend I would be went
in for a little bit unless we went to a
spot where nobody knew him and you know
I knew there was a hotel there and we're
just going to stay overnight and all
and then I would leave them there and
come back the next morning where is the
fun and living this life it wasn't that
much fun yeah that's what I mean I tried
to make my own fun I you know yeah you
know I did my own thing as much as I can
what is that doll I mean the you know
you you you ask from different guys
they'll say oh I lived in a 10,000
square foot home I had the Cadillacs I
had the cars I had the jewelry I had the
girls I would travel everywhere I would
go this that wasn't that wasn't you
that wasn't me no I didn't have that
life by choice well yeah that was my
life there was no choice there was no
intention I didn't even have an
intention that was my life you didn't
even choose to do that like if even if
you so I need used it but meaning I
guess what I'm asking is it's not in
your character to even be that way
switchers it's not okay that's what I'm
asking so you're not you're not in it to
say let me tell you you know I'm going
to go out I got the fur coat I'm you
know that's not at all you know zero you
could care less about that now
yeah are you making money at this time
yeah oh yeah we're all making money well
what's money what kind of money is
you're making a few hundred thousand a
year a few hundred thousand a year okay
and is your uncle making ten lakh
morning yes you're making ten it was
making millions he's making millions
he's making millions making a lot of
money what's his life looking like
what's what kind of a place is he live
in it what kind of fish is he a car guys
here jewelry lousy no so everybody's
pretty no he's pretty he lives in a
house a we had he lived in an apartment
in my grandmother's building mm-hmm and
the apartment what we did we made a big
house from three appointments we made a
big form you know the whole first floor
was his so he lived in the apartment he
never made his wife leave the
appointment because he figured the cops
would break in and bugged the place so
she never was allowed to leave and if
she did leave he was home you know I
lived in an apartment in Margate that
was it so if I don't know you you
wouldn't look like somebody that's got a
lot of money why I was dressed nice and
drove nice cars but I came off like I
have a lot of money we went to the
Harlem clubbing in Atlantic City they
invited us there because he had a couple
black fellas that were in the Union that
we used for strikes and all and so name
but I did this there they status in the
first row and had show
who's there the Harlem club which was
really nice and stuff like that he used
to like you know and used to like the
attention he got the newspaper when they
call him a killer and all that kind of
stuff he used to like that kind of stuff
what's the funnest you ever had being a
mobster what's the Florida one the boat
because I operate operated the boat no
one would go around I love that I could
have stayed on the boat all the time
yeah beautiful now you talk about a nice
desk we had a nice house in Florida it
was right on the water and for a
Lauderdale Fort Lauderdale called the
cash a blanket South Mickey did yeah
okay my uncle and you guys would go
there regular we would go to her so that
was the fun memories that was it okay
fine so so let's let's talk a little bit
about your uncle's personality what what
was he like so and what I mean by what
was he like I mean obviously in a minute
I want to get into what happens when you
become an underboss all of that but a
little bit about your uncle's
personality what what was his
personality like if he's in the room
right now and say he's at a peak of him
being a boss what would he be like what
kind of a person would he before going
out to you know what on what the type of
mood he's in if he's in a bad mood you
won't want to be around him he's out of
his mind he's crazy he's in a good mood
he's a likable guy he wasn't a nice guy
to be around
all the time like people that met him
would like them you know when cuz he
would you know he would condemn and all
but to be around him all the time when
you see how he really was how he treated
his wife and and what he did in his life
there's no good what was a turning point
for you were you you kind of started
thinking he's an evil man was there any
yeah what Sally well when we were going
to kill Sally that killed me that really
killed me that hurt me and and there was
nothing I could do about it
I could tell Savi and if I told him I
know he wasn't going to leave he was
going to start shooting and then what
was I gonna do that was it I couldn't
one led to that he got jealous to sell
my uncle was jealous that Sally's
getting a lot of attention
he was even written up in the Wall
Street Journal as a rising star in the
mob which really upset him and then you
know was always bad that this is a
mistake savvy me when my uncle was away
start going out with Chuckie rellenos
new murder
Maria and and my uncle as soon as he
heard that right away he thinks
Chucky and Salvi are going to get
together and go against them that's the
way he you know he thinks and it didn't
work after sale because she she didn't
work out for him you know she's to break
his balls and they just didn't click
together so he finally told my uncle he
said Nick he says I can't do this
anymore he says I want to break up with
Maria I just want to make sure it's okay
and my uncle says yeah no problem that's
fine that it's better to do it now
before you get married in law and then
he wanted to kill him after he told him
that he told Chucky he wants to kill him
why though because he was a very jealous
of him he was jealous he was a Joseph he
told me he says why do I have to take a
chance that he would want to make a move
on me and I'm thinking to myself he's
not going to make a move on you and if I
would have told him that
he's probably want to think that I'm
involved with Sal to make a move on him
that's the way this guy thought why did
you know for certain that he wasn't
gonna make a move on of course I know
Sal be my personality
I know his personality I knew him he was
with us he actually loved us he was part
of like he was like part of our family I
mean even when he got killed my mother
got so mad at me she she said how did
you let this happen you know and made me
sick
and I said I there's nothing like it
what could I do everything I read about
salvias he was likable he had he had the
two dimples he had the baby face he was
he gay he was yeah he was engaged yeah
but at the same time he had the values
he he was the loyal guy he wasn't a guy
that wanted to cross but do you see that
as a common trend with someone who comes
up aggressively like Nick did that
eventually you get to a point that you
worry and you become paranoid that
somebody could replicate exactly what
you did to someone else you think that's
the trend on what caused Nicky to think
that way your own thing could be he
trusts anybody he was getting older he
got the more paranoid he got about
everything and everybody
he started even at one time he said the
guy you need to start trusting Lawrence
he was hanging and Philadelphia start
hanging in Philadelphia a lot and he
said look I get guys in New York to come
here and wipe everybody out if you guys
start stopped listening to me he was
really starting to what cause that
though what why was it getting more
apparent the only time to get more
paranoid as if you're losing control
influence over your people well it
wasn't losing control because everybody
was scared to death of them and maybe
you know everybody was staying away from
home everybody was scared to do anything
if they did something they would you
know the word about getting killed
so you knew when Savvis hit was coming
before it happened yeah
how much longer after you knew it ended
up the hit took place I guess it was a
few months a few months why a few months
Joey sponge was was working on to try
and set him up because that was his best
friend we ran into Joey punch on the
beach and welcome so what else taking so
long
Joey said you know it's hard you know
we're trying you know we're trying to
get on me suspicious you know he says
I'm gonna tell you something if you
don't do this I'm gonna kill you your
father and your other brother so we got
done pretty fast after that good sob Ino
was coming he had an idea he had an idea
he was gonna get killed yet like I would
go to dinner with him like we would all
go to dinner me him Joey and Anthony and
all and and he would say Phil let me sit
there so I could see if somebody's
coming I said so if somebody's coming in
and ain't I going to tell you well he
was he was suspicious he thought he was
gonna get killed the moment had happened
what happened next well they killed him
in Joey grandi and Wayne he Grandy
killed them they wrapped him up and they
they dropped him inside of the road
somewhere
were you there or no no you weren't
involved with that one at all
you were you chose to not to be part of
or that was in yours now it wasn't no I
was in a vomit so that things move
pretty quickly after that or no back to
business as usual
yeah yeah he met with all the guys that
were in salvage crew and everybody said
yeah he should have told us we would did
you know we would help General David it
made me sick they were all saying that
they you know we would have listened to
you whatever you say Nick you're the
boss and all this they were kissing his
ass and it was it was sickening
you were there anyone yeah yeah I was
there with all the meetings along was
your was your uncle the kind of guy that
would ask so is so Phil what do you
think about this what do you think about
the situation
no he never asked me just tell me we'd
never ask me my opinion because he would
get suspicious
depending on what I would say I would
have said well you want to kill Sal
before I mean he's one of us so even if
he asked you would you have given your I
would have told him to you would well
you would have given you knowing he
could have been
Bish's yeah I don't care but you're
asking me I'm telling you the way I feel
I always told them the truth I know I
about anything I didn't cut any corners
who did he go to for counsel I know as a
consumer you got somebody to talk to say
what do you think about this nobody but
constantly air was my old uncle Nick who
was senile at the time you can't do much
with an adviser like that so so what
what is the story with skinny razor I
mean I I've read a lot on skinny razor
and skinny racer razor they say he was
the mentor to bosses skinny razor any
razor this fella from Philadelphia was a
was a made member of the Philadelphia
mob whose captain actually and he took
my uncle under his wing when my uncle
was young around 16 17 years old and my
uncle would hang with him alive and he
introduced my uncle to all the guys in
New York all the bosses and everybody he
knew he knew a lot of people and that's
how my uncle got to know everybody over
there and that's how they got to know my
uncle on his reputation it was he a
historian was the guy that knew the
history the mob or no skinny boys yes
yes skinny was me taught my uncle and my
uncle knew all the laws of the Cosa
Nostra do too skinny do too skinny
also skinny was a stone killer he killed
a lot of guys and that's how my uncle
got Bob well what killing people with
him so skinny skinny was known for being
a killer when you say in a lot of guys
what's what's the number with somebody
like him was he I had no idea dozens or
Z is it is it no I would say at least a
dozen I mean okay we'd kill people he
would he got the okay to kill this
fellow with my uncle that lived in South
Philadelphia now this fella was like in
a former for the police one day during
the snowstorm he grabbed my uncle said
come on let's go they walked in the
snowstorm because nobody was out driving
or anything they went in the store and
they killed this guy who was the
informer and they cut his balls off and
they stuck it in his mouth
and that's the type of guy my uncle was
and skinny razor
did you ever get a chance to meet skinny
no he died I never met him you never met
him now
but everybody knew who he was had a
reputation yes what did he die a vicious
way or was it just a he had a heart
attack I believe what a way to come in
in the mob world that's a good way to go
yeah right although Sammy said if
there's a way to go there's an the
is not a better way to go than to be
killed because you don't feel anything
if you get hit me you know if you get a
bullet in the head
yeah there's no way try to avoid you
want to try to avoid that's probably a
good idea to try to avoid it now Sammy
did you ever have any kind of a run-in
with Sammy we had a good relationship
yeah I mean Sammy my uncle we've really
good close friends so you would see each
other quite often we would see each
other's light yeah and was it a good
camaraderie respect for one another you
know accommodating towards each other
yes definitely yeah he's a good man Sam
he's a really really good person why do
you say that well we got close with him
you know Christ from the 70s I believe
my uncle and I met him with Frankie to
Chico and we just formed this
relationship we would see him every time
we went to New York for meetings and all
and especially when John Gotti became
the boss he came down to make an
appointment for us to meet with John
Gotti as the new boss and all he came
down Sammy came down and made the
appointment yeah with Sammy's reputation
somebody that followed the rules was a
proud mafioso himself because that's
what I've heard from a lot of people Sam
definitely definitely yes he definitely
followed the rules he's a good stand-up
guy so what are your thoughts about the
because there's two parties there's two
camps that once say you know he should
have never flipped in another part in
another camp says he did the right thing
where do you fall on this I mean this is
the world you were a part of right you
know what we did by testifying going
against our oath is something that we
grew up with this very hard to do and
for him to do it like like I did it I
know it it's hard when you get
double-crossed by your your boss I'm
glad he did it I think he made the right
move hopefully he has a good life you
know good life now and everything's okay
any other major names of guys had a
run-in with any other major names in the
Italian mafia world was it everybody at
the time I met everybody yeah we knew
everybody
Martita said he and his brother Michael
and too Mac of course they were coming
down the landing City a lot you name I
mean you know we met a lot of people did
you ever meet anybody more brutal than
your uncle no not as crazy sim there was
guys that killed a lot of people and all
but he enjoyed it he
we really enjoyed it and he he liked
doing it because he liked the reputation
after I got arrested for the pep you
leave a murder it came an article came
out by this guy Mike Sherman and they
called me crazy film I got upset about
that I said were they calling me crazy
Phil for and Michael said shut up he
said guys would pay money to have a
nickname like that alright that's the
way he thought purely a reputation guy
yeah now was he a fighter as well or
Noakes I know he did some kind of
amateur boxing amateur boxing nothing
have nothing so you never saw him fight
or you know yeah would people if it was
well women yeah we beat a few people
help me and him yeah you did yeah a
couple of guy a fella dead bothered if
somebody did it lived at my
grandmother's appointment we beat him up
and a couple people we have problems
with so you you were talking about
earlier when you said you know it got to
a point where you you were no longer
enjoying working with your uncle a
turning point you said was Salvi and
then after the turning point you're
still doing business as usual what leads
to you deciding to turn everything like
if the salary went like everybody really
got scared about everything things
weren't going good we said everybody's
like the crow got indicted and Tommy doe
they started to cooperate and we stop we
got indicted and I got so disgusted I
said if I'm thinking of myself if I beat
this case I'm going um soon as I get out
I'm leaving I'm taking my mother and my
girlfriend and we're heading out and it
just didn't work I thought I was going
if we won the first two cases but lost
the last case but I was the sky with him
because during that time during that
that federal case mark my cousin mark my
uncle's son hung himself
and the reason he hung himself because
his father wanted him to be involved
with the mob and the kid didn't want
nothing to do with the mob the kid was a
legitimate kid he was a sports kid a
nice kid he don't want nothing doing
anything the father kept calling names
you're a jerk-off if you dude if you
play sports you're a jerk-off and why
though why why why is he saying that
stuff to his kids because he thought the
kid should be like him and be a mob guy
and the kid didn't want to be a mob guy
so the kid left hung not only hung
himself he left a note saying why he did
it he couldn't take his father no more
all the pressure
and he signed it your jerk-off son mark
come on yeah who was the first person
that solved my mom it was in the
bathroom downstairs of course and what
he did he laid out all pictures of me
and him and on the bed we did it
how much longer after that that he died
he lived a long time in a coma was
horrible I told my uncle said look he
blamed my mother for him hanging that's
another thing your uncle blame your
mother he playing my mother for Mark
hanging himself he said your mother
always hollered at him I used to see the
vein in your neck coming out when she
would holler at Moore I said my mom
didn't holler and I said oh my god III
like couldn't say nothin he's hollering
at me in front everybody were in his
cell coming back from court and
naturally he told my mother to get rid
of the note he said throw it away so I
said I told my mom I didn't see her
right away I said don't throw that note
away keep it she says I already threw it
away
hmm what she told me what was on it was
horrible so you never confronted him and
that you've never confronted your uncle
no ever
no the only no the only time I got upset
one time with him you know scarfing my
company I had paid for a lot of stuff
airline tickets everything wherever we
went I said you know we should put some
money into the scarfing make it you know
make it legitimate you know he said [ __ ]
scarf Inc I said [ __ ] score think I said
it's paying for everything I said I must
be the biggest jerk around here no man I
really got upset that time and but that
was it that's always what was his
reaction you say anything you say
nothing so because he didn't do it often
he took it yeah did you ever want to
take him out I did yeah actually I did
after this would Sal be I didn't know
what to do you know I couldn't warn Sal
cause he wanted he would start a war
start shooting it up and all and I
wouldn't know what to do so I'm figuring
every time we're in the car you know
when we're back from Philadelphia we
always pull off the road we drive
somewhere into the woods and walk far
from the car when nobody's around I
figured it would be good spot to kill
him then I'm thinking then why
grandmother ma'am I gonna tell my
grandmother my you know not that she got
a long one I'm nobody got a long one I'm
but still you know I just couldn't do it
but I thought about a few different
spots to kill him every time you wanted
to kill him you went to your grandma is
that what you know I can't go to her I
don't know meaning in your mind you
going gonna have to face your grandma so
that's the reason why you didn't want to
yes pull the trigger was it very close
to that taking place were you're like oh
yeah because I already knew where we
would go and the spots I would do it in
but I fear what would have happened if
you did what would have changed what
would have changed up I would have left
because there's no way I was going to go
to New York and explain what happened to
him because you're done I wouldn't have
done that I was going I would he killed
them and then left with my mother and my
son and my wife you don't think it would
have caught you no matter where you
would have gone I would have to say now
really I would have to yeah yeah I don't
think they would have because you have a
place in your mind that you don't think
that would have gone to I would think
yeah I would think I'm pretty careful
and as far as looking for me I mean it's
not like I'm around doing business with
people where they could get their hands
on me no one to have to find out who
killed them how would they know who
killed if you don't go to New York to
sit with them they know I get an idea
they would get ideas you if you if you
faced and that could be a reason to say
on that scared so I'm only thinking
about like what was the breaking point
for you to say I'm not taking this
anymore
that was it I mean the way he was that
he was going off the board he was it was
crazy so now you guys get you get
convicted right this is now you're going
through court now what would led to that
what led to the point where you know
you're you're gonna go face your 45
years you know after the 10 murders
you're facing what led to that well
between shabby gang killed the mark
hanging himself I said what what are we
doing here
I mean we're killing ourselves I talked
to my mother I said look course I needed
her okay to do this I said I'm gonna
cooperate and we'll get out of here you
know we'll get away from this screwball
she said yeah good I'm glad
do it so that's why I did it I called up
Jim Moore who was an FBI agent I said
Jim do you know who this is she says no
I said I thought you were a voice expert
so I told him who it was and I'd like to
talk to them and all that and then we
said you know Jim Moore was there also
fellow named clouds or class roar he was
a head guy he was a he's a great he was
a great man
so he was a great man yeah I was the
head guy that was the head of that
unitary he was so he delivered on his
promises to you every
thing all of them guys did Gollum guys
so so when you met with him how much how
quickly did you cooperate after that and
is this the time when you were in jail
when you made the phone call yes I was
in jail
oh so you had already gone to jail so
both you and Nicky at this point are
arrested you're arrested I'm waiting to
get sentenced actually you're waiting to
get sent so they would say wait till
after sentencing and then we'll talk so
he's completely elsewhere is he had were
you f he was in one prison in
Philadelphia but I don't know I might
have been in Holmesburg at that time you
don't member one of them one of the
prisons in Philly I mean it sounds like
you've been a couple different places so
you know it's in a few different place
yeah so you can't remember which one it
was but he definitely wasn't at the same
one you were at no at that time are you
in communication with him at the time
well so was through Nicky Nicky become
visitors he would send messages Nicky
his son his son okay outside of his son
Nicky what's the last conversation you
and him had actual conversation the UN
the actual this one was him yelling to
me about something with Bobby Simone
they tell him to get on the the case our
appeals and all this was after Bobby
your attorney Bobby D Bobby Simone
shorty attorney and as he was telling
that they were closing the door last
thing you remember this thing that was
it that's the last time I seen him and
what your was that 89 mile Wow 1989 31
years ago so so then you go to Jim you
tell him hey I'm willing to cooperate
yeah how quickly is a decision made then
are you willing shooting with them and
you're saying if I do this what will you
do for me I'll say that take place how
did I do
I said you know I'm looking to cooperate
you know and he went sure I said you
said yeah so they came to pick me up the
marshals came to Otisville where I was
at that time and picked me up and that
was it and they took me and from there I
started to cooperate with him so they're
not negotiating at all I didn't
negotiate anything about time or stuff
like that I hopefully you know I told
them hope you could do something with my
sentence and all you know I just talked
to him about everything before any any
papers resign or anything so so then
you're going back and forth is this when
you know you took this approach and then
what what were some of the leaders and
bosses
were affected by you being an informant
are you coming out and talking well I
was I testified in the windows case in
New York with Charlie Rose he was the
prosecutor at that time he was a another
nice man that passed away he was a good
guy I testified couple couple different
families in Connecticut I testified
trying to think there's so many cases I
read an article somewhere that John
Gotti was also affected by John Gotti I
was supposed to testify against him this
is what they did they brought me to New
York to testify in that trial but they
wanted to see how Sammy did first and
Sammy knocked it out of the ballpark so
I didn't testify so you went first you
were the highest-ranking under a member
to come out and be in a foreman and then
how much longer after you went out Sammy
came out a couple years two years okay
got it two years were you in
communication with each other at all at
that time or no while I'm with Sam you
reaching out you know while I was
cooperating while you were bothering not
at all no and so so you cooperate then
they reduce it from 45 years to five
years to six yes six and a half I went
up serving five years five months and
five days intentional is that was
accidental the fact that it's five years
five months five years that's the way it
worked out that's with good time that's
what I served five years five months
five days very interesting so while you
were and were you in with anybody else
well I was in yeah I've won a few
different guys a couple guys from New
York drug dealers and all that but yeah
I met Sammy Sammy came there for a
little bit I was with him how long were
you guys together had to be here I think
well you guys every day together talk
that was good it was great really it was
great and you guys are both pretty much
in the same situation
yeah it was well it was really good at
the time went by with him I'm up by
really fast it's a great storyteller
he's great he's very energy is great and
then you Geno Milano's showed up there
other guys I talked that were all there
prisons I talked to them on the phone
while you were in did anybody bother you
or no no did they know who you were yeah
they knew and they didn't want to cross
you yeah nobody bothering nobody broth
no it wasn't that type of prison anyway
you know if everybody there is is a
cooperator and also
oh I got it so buddies coop so they're
always trying to find a way to protect
all of you
yeah because everyone's somehow
cooperating right okay yes so when you
came out when you're in there what are
you thinking when I get out I'm never
going back to the light I don't want any
I'm done I'm yeah I was way done 100%
100% I got out you know you hooked up
with my my wife and my mom and my son we
moved and I started you know working and
and everything's working out it's so
much better where I could sleep at night
and I have nobody bothering me what a
great life it is being not in the mob
what a great life it is being not in the
mom yeah it how did you prevent your own
son from not wanting to take that route
by cooperating Phillip was really good
in math my son my uncle said told me my
will make him a bookmaker I see yeah
think so
and you told him you know let him go to
school what you know that's that's what
he wants to do with all our family once
they get him hooked up in the mob and so
yes I was never like ah you know I kind
of want that fear the way they respected
you dad you know he was going to school
and in the school you know my name would
be in the paper the same name as him I
mean you know you have problems with the
kids they'd give him a hard time because
of who I was you know it was bad he
couldn't go to you know he couldn't
concentrate in school was a mess it was
a problem so the best thing to do would
you get out of here it worked out for
everybody get out of then go to a
complete different place clean your
mouth and start all over again this is
when you went into not wanting to show
your face no voice no nothing when's the
last time you woke up in the morning
worried about your life never never
since you left no the only time I'd
worry about my life was I had kidney
cancer my right kidney and they took it
out this my doctor from Italy mm-hmm and
that was it was fine it was ten years
ago what you feel like when know when
your uncle died in 2017 what we no
feeling at all nobody's want to miss him
I said what he would say about everybody
that died nobody miss him I don't even
think about him my name yeah I wish he
would have lived a hundred years just in
the
he was in I wish you would have made his
full term when you're by yourself and no
one's around and you're kind of
reflecting thinking about him the fact
that your father wasn't in the picture
he kind of replaced that there you have
some kind of a loyalty tool or not at
all you know yeah making me a mob guy
and a killer and all that now I have a
zero at all at all
so that shifted for you as you were
going through it and well I mean look
what he did I mean it it's not only his
faults my fault too I went along with
them and you know I'm not saying but he
showed me the ropes he showed me what to
do and made me pretty good
you know assassinated were you
cold-hearted guy yourself no I'm not
cold-hearted I am NOT cold-hearted at
the peak of it no he's never
cold-hearted but look when I killed
somebody that was looking to kill me I
don't consider that to be cold I'm
killing other bad people yeah I wish you
know no guilt at all about telling the
guys no not til today no I'm no guilty
they would have killed me I mean we're
this is what we do we're mob guys
especially our mob we killed people no
nightmares middle of the night no cold
sweat no waking up thinking about
someone's family kids any of that no if
I had that that would have been a big
problem being in the mob no it would
have been a big problem at the time of
become yeah so so how about a UH you
know the story that you know Falcone you
know Vincent Falcone you you end up a
Marion his ex-girlfriend
yes that doesn't mess with you at all
why would it mess with me I asked this
to the normal guy to a normal guy this
is a guy you were hanging out with you
know it's like I'm getting together with
your girl that doesn't do anything to
you I married a girl that he was dating
yeah it just happened to work out that
way I mean I wasn't going out with her
while he was you know dating her after
he died I was I didn't start going out
with her until like maybe a year later
it's just because she lived right across
the street from me and it just worked
out that way you know we just hooked up
and got along you know sometimes when
folks in a military talk and you don't
understand where they're talking their
language sometimes if somebody's
civilian they don't some what it is to
be military sometimes when you speak to
folks from your world you speak very
matter-of-fact you know they're you know
this is
just kind of what we did is it's the
life I chose to live and it's not but to
somebody that's not in your world
they're maybe looking are saying so this
kind of sounds crazy to to live like
race yeah we had to be crazy to be in
the mob yes but this is the way I grew
up and this is what I was involved in I
mean this is this that was my life let
me ask you did you ever have any run-in
with Meyer Lansky yes we stood meet him
in Florida during the 70s at the Eden
Roc hotel we used to meet him that
sounds like plural like multiple it's
not just once
oh we met him a few times there yeah we
used to see every time we went to
Florida we would meet him my uncle made
Chucky
a Nick Rosen one of his guys was there
he I can't sir at all and it's me at
that time and we were getting them
drinking shots you know he had a
handkerchief here and drinking shots and
all it was it was exciting it was a
great guy I mean so it was a little old
man walking a little dog little white
dog I remember and you would talk about
the old days his buddy Danny and it was
just exciting they had something to do
with a Monte Carlo and the casino there
they wanted to send my own there with
his wife but my uncle said no I'm gonna
go with my girlfriend he said no no you
got to go with your wife if we send you
there really yeah
so he was that discipline too so you
can't go with your girlfriend can go
with you I told him that was it a values
thing or oh we don't want it to be
public what was his reason it was I
don't know but he you know he felt like
it wouldn't it's not right to go with
your girlfriend I guess very now how did
you guys view him did you view him as
somebody that was one of the greatest
earners of all time in the way yeah I
did I did I looked up to him like a
guide I mean Meyer Lansky you write
about him you know you hear all over him
all over the world about this guy it was
amazing it was amazing just sitting
there listening to him and meat and
shaking his hand and he the stories that
stuck with you that he told about ban
award that he told about just said could
smell or any of those guys he just about
Benny look you know how much he liked
them in the broke his heart when he got
killed but you know he can't do what he
did you know you can't rob the cassini
can't rob the mob was he as rich as
everybody said he was you know I don't
know he didn't look rich to me but who
knows I mean you know I mean the numbers
they say about him is like he had
five hundred to five hundred million to
billion dollars he must have been very
very smart that's all I could say did
you ever watch him in an interview he
did with the Israeli TV back in 1971 no
I want to show this to you and see see
see how see how you see this for
yourself if he was like this when he
spoke to you because here he's kind of
playing off that he's just a regular guy
you know that he's not connected at all
this is the interview mr. Lansky why are
the American authorities up to you
because a newspaper man started a
campaign against me and it's snowball to
such an extent that I guess it can be
stopped anymore
I was singled out for some reason they
needed an image and this has gone to an
extent where is just no world and I
don't know how far it's gonna go and one
devious noble well actually started
about 1965 when some newspaperman wrote
an article that I have 300 million
dollars well I wish I had a million
dollars
I said many more things remember I've
been said about me they accused me of
making a president now I don't know mr.
Nixon any more than what I read in the
newspapers and the closest I ever got to
him the same amount television they
claim I have 50% of Lebanon casinos 50%
of Monte Carlo the ruse will sent me to
visit the teaster
on a mission now how ridiculous can we
really get this is just the goal I say
is long enough you'll get the people to
believe I think he's smart man he's a
character man I'm saying that when he
mentioned Richard Nixon there was a
story Michael told me about [ __ ] DeCarlo
who was in prison at that time he was
dying to cancer and they gave Nixon what
[ __ ] DeCarlo gave him like a half a
million dollars to pardon him half a
million dollars to pardon oh yeah Wow
and how how fax you think that is that
story's been told by others oh I don't
know well you kick it down I guess I'm
interesting
Nicky took you to sit down with Meyer
what was the reasoning for that was it
just because you were here yeah was his
nephew I was there okay you could trust
me was me Chuckie
it was our crew Lawrence why was why was
Myra comfortable talking to you guys
what they liked my uncle I mean he was
really you know my are like your uncle
he loved them
he really every time we would come there
he would come over to the eating rock
and and see him why why do you think
well he knew his reputation and my
priority guy yeah he knew guys from New
York that he know and you like that and
how did Nicky look here how did your
uncle look at him he looked up to him
admiration yeah definitely yeah okay
you really did would you question some
of the stuff like him being worth 300
million or him having fixed the
president would you say it's possible
that he could have yes it's possible I
believe that yeah oh yeah I knew he had
something to do with Monte Carlo he said
it so they send my uncle there I mean
there's some there's some real strong
stories about him that you know maybe
we'll get into another time but on how
much influence he had you know with the
businesses Cuba politics presidents all
of it okay interesting
I got a few pictures I want to show you
on characters to see what your immediate
reaction is going to be these are some
folks that you may have done some kind
of a business dealings with so let me
pull it up Mario is it gonna be okay
first of all let's start off with movies
are you big mob movie
or no some of them yes dinero did
anything with De Niro yeah if I give you
some names can you just tell me if you
you know what kind of reaction yet to
the movies Bugsy did you watch Bugsy I
did what do you think about it it was
okay it was already what I was a
Hollywood movie
didn't do anything for ya how about
black mass I didn't see that one
that's the Johnny Depp y-yeah watch that
old
how about Goodfellas I liked it yeah it
was great pretty accurate the story your
life was like yep
Godfather a Hollywood movie really yeah
you're not a big Godfather no I am I
think it was a great it's a great movie
there's a depict of life this yeah it
does it does is that the closest one I
think either Goodfellas would be closer
Goodfellas would be gonna be closer than
your father yeah interesting how about
Donnie Brasco Donnie Brasco was okay it
was alright Jim ever have any dealing
with Joe Pistone her now never okay how
about Scarface with Al Pacino yeah I
like Al Pacino but it was okay them kind
of movies in casino you know he liked I
liked that one a lot we're Oscar going
and imperfect in a row new job any
dealings Glasgow Goodman no just that he
represented me also he did represent you
yes good experience no not really it was
yeah I mean one day he came to court
with a big cut over his eye Chris they
were drunk the night before and the
saloon and they felled then he fell down
and slit his eye lid on the on the curve
they were having a good time maybe
dealing with Tony Spilotro or now no
okay
how about Once Upon a Time in America
that was good I enjoyed that movie one
of my dad's favorite Bronx Tale I
enjoyed that too good one yeah
Carlito's Way it was that was it okay
how about mobsters with Christian Slater
no Myra Lansky is this story I know that
wasn't my earliest so your number one
would be Goodfellas yeah yeah I like
Goodfellas did you watch Irish Man I did
would you think about it it was a good
movie but it's not true it's not true no
no that guy didn't know Frank Sheeran
didn't kill all them people how how
could I have a confident are you about
the fact that he I'm very confident
here's the guy from Philadelphia Union
guy probably a tough guy you know big
guys up that are strong you know
one strikes an all-union but he was in
the killer he was you know I mean why
did the mob why do we have to hire him
to kill or kill people and they actually
I think in the movie they actually paid
him which you don't get paid when you
kill people in the mob you're not on the
payroll if you're given an assignment
you just do you do it yes how a bonus
for it yeah no I mean you have your own
business but no was it frustrating
watching like you're like I know for a
fact this isn't true or did you just
kind of like what select an arrow okay I
like all them guys in it was big there
was really good like Joe Pesci it was
great
and by the way several people have also
said the same thing you said about the
fact that you know there was not much
truth behind it a few characters I want
to show you just to curious to know what
kind of reaction we're gonna get what do
you think about when you see his picture
here Frankie flowers do Alfonzo okay now
Frankie flowers my and my uncle gave him
a lot of chances you know he had the
closed-circuit TV with the boxing and
made a ton of money and my uncle wanted
his end you know and I kept telling
anyone do it you weren't he wouldn't do
it he won't pay so we beat him up bad
but he put him in the hospital for a few
months you know I mean he came out he
still didn't pay said he killed him when
he said beat him I bet he states in a
hospital for a few months wouldn't mean
beat him up and beat him up we broke
everything in his body
I think Salvy and Gino beat him with
iron pipes with the intention of killing
them or just bring him my uncle told him
say yeah make sure you kill him okay you
know beat him up bad but if he dies he
dies that's how it was but he lived and
when he woke up he said he thought he
got hit by a truck not sure he didn't
say anything what did I think he didn't
still come and say okay let me work with
you yeah I guess he wanted the money I
don't know he didn't want to give us
money yeah interesting how about I have
Tony oh that's Angelo Bruno when you see
that picture you think about anything
any emotions any feelings Angelo Bruno
said he was to reach the comb lefty
because he was always trying to send
this like trick us somehow so no you
didn't trust them no not at all
how about Donald Trump Donald Trump I
didn't know him when he was young now
that leads to president I don't think
he's doing such a great job
so in Atlantic City he had no dealings
with them well we we did but not not
naturally not me personally we had a
club called a lava Stroke Club
and we sold that club to Donald Trump
got it and he knew he was buying it from
you guys he shouldn't know him cuz I
think he made a statement he says those
guys are stupid like he is he says I
would have paid twice as much for that
building your man let's give this one
here Oscar Goodman yeah you know I don't
see the score in this picture doing on
top we should be the only guy in flowed
off you he's a good guy good guy yeah he
was a nice he wasn't a bad guy Joe the
gambie and all the guys have filled up
he's the only one I like he is the worst
human being alive this guy right here
Joey Merlino horrible human being why do
you say that he's a harp he robbed you
know he actually robbed Joe punch it to
his mother's jewelry
Joe punch it to his mother was sleeping
on a couch in her house in the
summertime you know doors are open
everybody's in and out he went in there
seen her sleeping went upstairs and grab
Bowl or jewelry and took it all so he
beats everybody bars money never pays
nobody back when my uncle was in jail I
would collect my uncle sent from Chuckie
it was always short and it wasn't
Chuckie taken and I know he was taking
it you know he few hundred here if you
hunt it every time I got money was if
you wanted short and I don't want to say
nothing to Chuckie about it but that's
Joey Merlino lowlife you ever had a
run-in with him you ever had any
experiences well no it was like younger
when I was around age to calm Jose did
he have any kind of connection to Johnny
gangs or no well I think he was friendly
with him he was friendly with them as
far as I know I mean you know I wasn't
around at that time do you know the
rumor about Johnny the gangs who you
know he would sit by his Corvette and
put a $20 bill up top of a saint if
anybody can knock me out they get to
take that $20 bill really you know that
story now okay yeah apparently he was a
tough guy the reason why they call him
guys is because when he would hit you
you know gongs the sound you would you
would feel it you didn't you didn't have
any experience with them no okay no
interesting okay how about Johnny see no
I didn't know him you didn't know him
okay
Oh chill fine yes we knew judge Hill
fine
he was a crooked judge we paid him
$12,000 to get 12 15 I don't know what
it was
the complain was going to get sense for
murder and we told him he said he could
get it like two to three years for he'll
pay to judge 15,000 and we gave him the
money the blade got 12 and a half
fifteen so he just you know beat us for
the money he just beat you for the money
in what is the story would judge where
he came around and ask for a favor to
help him out because he was facing some
challenges and your uncle he was on
trial it was a trial and there was a guy
testifying against them in Atlanta in
the land yeah
so Harold Garber who was representing
him at that time
got my uncle and to fly to Atlanta to
talk to this guy but my uncle actually
didn't
my uncle sat here the guy who knew who
my uncle was and then Harold sat here
with the guy talking to him my uncle's
just looking at the guy to help judge
he'll fly now so the guy wouldn't
testify against them but knowing his
mode of your uncle's motive was bigger
than that oh yeah he knew he would get
killed in other words the guy testifying
against hell fine
no my uncle would kill him if he would
oh yeah yeah I know that but but what
I'm asking is was there a bigger motive
that your uncle wanted to oh yeah well
straighten things out with him because
he was planning closed doors kind of
throwing your uncle under the bus yes
he didn't want him to go to jail he
wanted him on the street so we could
kill him he wanted to do the job he
didn't want somebody else to do the job
yeah he wanted nicked the blade to kill
him say no how was Mickey Coco attached
to this any at all or Mickey Coke was a
couple different story
no he's at different Mickey Coke was the
guy that was selling drugs to Frank
Monty his son yes okay no relation to
this at all
no okay got it interesting okay Meyer
Lansky we spoke about exactly what he
was good he was troubled he had demons
because this young one of his kids
drowned you know when he was younger and
ever since then he was never right he
was he was a good guy dough but when he
would drink he wasn't allowed to drink
around us until like midnight he was a
good person I'll tell you a story would
he you know a fella bit of beep was
around this he was a bookmaker for us
Anthony for our side his name was and
was to hang in a place called Harry to
hats in Atlantic City and how he would
have gambling going on in the back so
bit of beep who was in there gambling
with these fellas they were robbing them
you know they had them for like two
three thousand dollars the blade comes
in a beat what he doing he says you know
I'm gambling and he sees everybody here
he knows they're all hustlers he says
get up I'm playing for him dealt the
cards he said
buddy look I says I win and until he got
all the money back that's the type of
guy he was he wasn't a spot for the
little guy fight for the little guy
France II would call him Anthony then
you got all those money back and and
took more of course he would shake
people down because they knew he was
crazy he was qualified crazy qualified
great huh yeah you see this picture what
do you think about poor mark my cousin
mark and Nikki got 30 years for nothing
wasted lifes wasted lives and it's my
uncle's fault does a Nick at all reach
out to have yet any kind of
communication with them
I had communications with him after I
got out of prison okay early around nine
eighty five five ish and I told him what
are you doing
get out of here I said you could come
with me I mean we're all set up you'll
be fine you'll make money you work you
have a nice life he said yeah he was
thinking about it but he was on his way
to prison for like 18 months or
something he was had a short bit to do
and that was it
when his own way and let her being there
for 39 now he's never yeah 30 years
that's his life uh you see a picture
like that your uncle yeah I remember
that day we went to Washington he was in
front of the Senate committee what
memories does it bring back nah that's
memories all kinds of memories of him
how crazy is he was a really evil evil
man that so many horrible stories that
I'm even embarrassed to talk about to
you you know of course it's my family
that Paul Muni was that his inspiration
that's it that's this hero that's the
guy he wanted to be
that's the guy he was not in a public
boat that's it just keep killing you got
to keep killing got to do this he says
he's got to keep doing it okay Peter
Casella that's the guy that killed Phil
they got lucky he got away
you remember that yeah I know I was here
I seen it that was a game-changer for
you that's where a major decision was
made for you that's we're a Phil testa
was killed
yeah and yeah I mean that's when you
know which this is actually when we
started to make money after my uncle
became the boss that's when we really
started making big money so this was a
positive turning point for you yeah I
hate to say it
this is the this is this is far right
yeah yeah yeah Chucky Chucky was a good
guy
he was a good good person he had a
drinking problem at the end and a
numbers because of my uncle drove him
crazy
and so I mean my Sonny after him you
named your son after yourself you get
emotional when you think about him yeah
of course it's my fault yeah good you
hear the story and you hear all these
different sides to the story right
family you're in it looking back now you
completely made a transition and you've
left it's very hard to do was there ever
a moment where you're tempted to look
back and get back into it or never never
never announced that oh no I get it
I'd rather kill myself then go back oh
why yes not even a thought not even a
thought no do you think that model of
how they were rent running back in the
70s and 80s possible today no no why
because of all the the cameras they have
today that the police officers the FBI
all the surveillance they have you can't
you got to be really just to kill
somebody got to be really careful today
today I mean he was looking at my uncle
wanted to kill somebody in the casino
back then we could have did that back
then you know to break balls can't do
that today we can't well no cameras
there everyone you ever seen a movie
primal fear nobody sounds from my primal
fears with a guy named Edward Norton yes
with the Richard Gere you ever seen it I
mind if I did a long time ago so let me
ask you this question and I'm curious to
know what you're gonna what you're gonna
say to this in the movie primal fear
Edward Norton plays a role of this guy
who has two personalities right and he
is asked by the priest to do some stuff
that inappropriate like the priest would
bring him in and another girl and take
your clothes out do this to her do that
to her this is the story line of the
movie and eventually he snaps and he
kills them in the movie okay Edward
Norton and he gets caught he gets
arrested Richard
year ends up becoming his attorney and
while he's going through with them
pushes him one time when he's asking
tough questions then all of a sudden
this guy his name is Aaron and he
stutters Aaron turns into Roy and
Royce's tough guy you know push and
Challenger like you can't push Roy and
Roy almost protects Aaron so he's got
two personalities right okay I watched
you last time we go to dinner together
and I watch you if I don't know you you
come across like a really nice guy
easygoing chill you're good father you
want to do your best you want to be a
good family man are there two
personalities to fill is there the
regular feel that we know of and is
there the yeah crazy fill there is yeah
well yeah I don't like that nickname but
yeah I was a killer in the mob and I
left that in my mind to try and make
myself normal I separated that life and
a normal life so when I was with my
uncle and you know we would kill
somebody where we had a plan killing
people that's that's what I did and I
was really really good at it and that's
why he liked me if I wasn't good at it
he wouldn't even care about me you know
that's the type of guy he was
and then when I would be away from him
I'm trying to have a normal life you
know I've become myself then I won't be
that other person so the real you is not
it's not the nickname that you don't
like it's not the month the real you is
the the easygoing family yourself that's
that's that's the real that's it man
okay that's that's that tells you the
power of influence when somebody gets
ahold of you now what would have
happened if your uncle was a businessman
say your uncle was a doctor he was a
accountant he was a financial adviser
and he was very very good and he decided
to mentor you who would you have turned
out to be exactly what he was God would
have been really and that would have
been normal that would have been my
normal self I wouldn't have to be
somebody else that I didn't want to be
you know it would have worked out better
how does somebody who's in the spell of
somebody like that how does somebody
leave that life when they're too
how to think about an eighteen-year-old
Phil they're by the way they're
everywhere just so you know there's a
lot of guys that are connected to the
wrong family and there's bad habits
right you see a lot of different
communities is there a formula to leave
at that age when you're naive and you
don't know everything if you know
because you're young you're not smart
you know you really don't know
everything even though you think you do
and that's why I wrote this book to show
people that the mom's not glorious like
newspapers make it you know it's there
all backstabbers and cutthroats and
they'll kill you just to take over your
business maybe you know make up lies
about you so they could get in and make
money it's all about money we're in the
mob to make money
that was our besides killing everybody
we make money last thing is speed round
I'll give you some names tell me the
first one word that comes to mind okay
just one word that comes to mind
Jim Marr good man good FBI agent name is
fair Tommy Bell it was a drunk was a
drunk Oscar Goodman he wasn't as good as
I thought as a lawyer John Gotti when we
men we've nice nice too with us you know
it's about a wino Sal testa he it was my
buddy chickie Marucci he was no good
he was a look he killed Phil to become a
boss he was money hungry he was power
hungry he thought he was a big shot
Sonny Franzese I don't know you don't
know no my differencies nothing with
those two families okay and last but not
least Nicky Scarfo one word gangster one
word gangster gangster that's it that's
what it is and it's when he went out as
your gangs that's what he wanted to be
so you got it feel you're not somebody
that there's a lot of interviews so
meaning this is not like you're gonna go
do rounds because you're going out there
doing five ten on these interviews
that's not your style now what do you
want people to be thinking about I mean
there's only a couple things out there
to to watch what you're thinking about
final thoughts here final thoughts for
before we obviously encourage folks to
go read the books I read the book myself
what are your final thoughts for the
viewer right now to understand what I'm
talking about
I mean I mean we're not just not to
glorify them up the mobs on it
you know it's nice looking at the mob
from the outside but when you're in the
mob and you're dealing with members it's
not the same thing
you know the mob wants you to like them
so they could get money from you or do
favors for them and you know and try and
trap you just stay far away from any
organized crime people stay as far away
from you as you can maybe it wasn't
appropriate no matter you know any
worker any criminals I mean you know
you're not gonna wind up they don't care
about legitimate people I mean you're
not gonna wind up in a good position
they're the ones with the guns they're
the gangsters you know first of all
thank you for coming out and sitting
down and being willing to talk to us I
mean obviously last night there was a
complete different perspective and then
today to be able to do this where a lot
of the audience was wanting to hear from
you to see what your thoughts are after
all these different folks that have
showed up what I will tell if you're
watching this is do wait this this this
book is written the way this book is
written is how I like books to be
written because I'm getting the story
and then I'm getting an argument and
then I'm getting inside from the point
of view of Phil and the things he
experienced so if you haven't yet read
this book if you're somebody that enjoys
the mob interviews that we do and you've
read all the other books you got to go
read this one as well we're gonna leave
the link below for you to go watch
before you go order the book and read it
for yourself mafia prints inside
America's most violent crime family and
the bloody fall of La Cosa Nostra by
Philip Leonetti again if you haven't
ready click on the link philip once
again thank you so much for making the
time to come out here and hear thank you
again appreciate you you know it's
interesting from watching the interview
from your perspective because you can't
see any facial reaction I can tell you
from myself sitting right across from
the last couple hours there were moments
where the more we got deeper into
talking about his uncle Nicky you could
tell the absolute frustration with them
okay like absolute frustration with him
when he was talking about it but there
was also part when we talked about I
don't know if you caught that when I was
shown the pictures and it was salvie
testa and he saw the picture you didn't
see it he got emotional uh-uh
very obvious there was his eyes got
filled with teary-eyed and he swiped it
because he didn't want to look at the
picture anymore you could tell he has
some regret about what happened and it
was a very sincere emotion that you felt
that because you know there's a lot of
people I've interviewed on him upset and
some of them went in and it was great
life we did this we did that this was
not you noticed the part when I asked so
how was a life like were you partying
were you doing this so it was a
different kind of an interview
definitely a different kind of an
interview to hear a story of somebody
that wants nothing to do with it and
wished he never had anything to do with
it and I want to hear your thoughts how
different this is then some other
interviews we've done in the past so if
you can comment below on what your
biggest takeaway was from this one and
again if you haven't watched the oscar
goodman interview that he and I did
oscar goodman was an attorney to a lot
of different folks in the the crime
world if you haven't watched that click
on this to watch the oscar goodman
interview and if you haven't watched a
Sammy the bull Gravano interview click
over here and if you haven't subscribed
to the channel please do so thanks for
watching take care bye bye
you
[Music]